votre pièce de théâtre c'était quand la
dernière fois est aussi tourné en
tournée dans toute la france
oui c'est vrai dire tiens à vous toyota
gt à caudry et aussi je vous donne sur
mer et ça s'est très bien passé merci
bien merci
juste au tout la table book moi c'était
qu'on va justement parce que votre pièce
s'appelle c'était quand la dernière fois
c'est quand votre dernière fois benjamin
castaldi
t'as fait quoi sexuellement parlant bien
sûr oui non oui je m'attends sexuel ce
matin voilà parti à chasseurs oui j'ai
lu je ne vous demanderai pas je vous
saute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la pièce ne parle pas de sexualité
monsieur d'encore amoureuse de son mari
mais elle préfère le tuer donc d'emblée
lui dit au début de la pièce chérie tu
vas mourir dans une heure trente est
venue la salade croyez vraiment que je
posais la question de l'être mais vous
les joies mais oui mais alors pas
sexuellement alors vraiment répondre
sexuellement donc obligé de patrick tu
devrais dire la vérité
mais là ce matin
non vous aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le reste bouge encore à patrick faut que
je réponde aussi alors mot de passe pour
coucher j'espère bien alors c'était bon
bah c'était récemment bon voulurent
membres après patrice réfléchir monsieur
vous vous voyez pas faire un nom à
l'allée au schéma comment il fait lui
parce que moi j'ai mal au dos et il lui
il arrive avec la jambe cassée alors non
mais c'est pas la journée
il a débattu mais quand on a très mal au
dos battu voilà alors qu'en espagne a
longtemps non bâti le mal de dos baby
gym à qui mon fils va avoir 17 ans donc
18 ans je me bats toi c'était quand la
dernière fois dans de lourds après opéra
qu'envers à quoi - de mélo m s'associe à
vivre mais savoir aussi un mandat ça
suffit d'arrêter de vous reposer
régulièrement battus mais voilà la
raison
on va valérie
marquer c'est pas ma carrière je me suis
passionné la nuda je réprouve à tout et
qui se répondent et maintenant c'est moi
d'abord on fait appel on sait qu'il est
chef et où j'aime ça pour moi c'est des
règles eh oui la dernière enfin tour de
table que la presse s'intéresse à la
chef ici alors il ya quelques quelques
heures en vacances quelques mots à moi
d'un mois cette affluence messaoui
recevant voilà seulement titania staff
là ça va finir par astana va tomber
c'était sur une gondole mal au dos moi
c'est un peu tout ça oui c'est un peu
tendu dans le coupe donc ça monte un peu
ce midi avec moi je suis donc ça fait 10
ans 20 ans savent pas mais c'est grave
en fin de semaine dernière byers oui à
lakota
non non non c'est vraiment parce que
j'ai été malade et pour parler
vulgairement quand je suis malade j'ai
pas besoin alors y'a quelqu'un autour de
cette table avec ma connu quand j'étais
encore en mains quand j'étais avec elle
vient pas avec la loi tepa et dans les
années 90 et j'avais voilà j'avais à huy
donc ça remonte au début des années 90
oui ça remonte à patrick sera là il m'a
patrick n'ont pas assez précis
[Applaudissements]
je suis à 90 très très bel et bien dans
les années 90
pas possible ça vous va faire 20 ans a
bien sûr que si on ne sait pas tout ce
mario
oui bah oui on l'appelle le train
fantôme ben oui quelques semaines encore
dit la vérité
ah ben je vous jure pas clair ne pas
répondre quand même ils répondent ça moi
la semaine dernière non parce que
j'avais des tournées de dingue mais la
semaine d'avant oui oui quoi faire alors
vas-y indiqué moi ca de 3 ans non les
minots ajouteront alors été arrêtés
trois filles